[music]
our monastery was closed in 1920 and
according to the order of the then
authorities, an end camp for political prisoners of foreigners was set up here,
and
there was also a women's prison here,
and of course this time was probably
special in the history of our Novospassky by
terry  since here people
endured, one might say
, they endured torment, they who
were shot here
[music]
if you walk around the territory of our
Novospassky monastery,
you will find the so-called Italian
courtyard,
this is the place where
people of these political prisoners were shot at that time,
according to the testimony of our parishioners still living by the
way  the
groan of the Novospassky monastery atmu was so much more audible
than their people that the authorities decided to put speakers around the
perimeter of our monastery
where
some kind of music was sung almost around the clock or something was
said, some texts, yes, in order
to drown out the
groan, the grief of the grief of those people who are there
much  that is, we have here in the
Spassky monastery
[music]
it is impossible to count on the
Butovo training ground alone where the bodies of
our holy martyrs are buried, some more than
10,000
and it seems there are figures that I heard it
up to 30,000 people that were
shot there  or buried sometimes could be
shot here with us
and buried in other places
[music]
I look at it in a Christian way from a
Christian point of view, of course, for
many people these times will seem
very scary for
humanity in general for the person as a whole, because
the murder took place
correctly  from the point of
view of the Christian church, human blood is strengthened
in the days when persecution is carried out, our
church has become even stronger, but
imagine if one of the
people who do not know Christ and do not believe
in him could know something, but do not believe,
shed it truly with love  there is no blood for him,
and now we have these examples and for
us this statement of faith  in Christ,
because after all, those people turned out to be there,
despite already more than 1000, 900 years
after the coming of Jesus Christ, but they did not
suffer again,
as they suffered in the times where the
criteo is now the Rhone,
when the axon, we also acquired martyrs
[music]
and